el partido socialista de nicolás maduro
y sus seguidores celebran lo que llaman
una victoria popular la asamblea
nacional la única institución que aún
estaba en manos de la oposición ahora
pasó al control de los chavistas nicolás
maduro se mostró eufórico con el
resultado
hemos cumplido con la constitución hemos
cumplido con esta constitución cinco
años después tengo que salir a decir
tenemos una nueva asamblea nacional
producto del voto popular el pueblo ha
elegido a sus nuevos diputados a sus
nuevas diputadas y hemos tenido una
tremenda y gigantesca victoria electoral
a pesar de su triunfo la jornada
electoral estuvo marcada por una muy
alta abstención el consejo nacional
electoral compuesto por partidarios de
maduro admitió que la participación fue
realmente baja y con una participa
del 31 por ciento de las electoras y
electores un creep la oposición que
boicoteó la elección la ha catalogado
como fraudulenta en cambio convocó a una
consulta en línea para rechazar los
comicios y exigir la salida de maduro el
líder opositor juan guaidó dijo que
mantendrá sus funciones como presidente
encargado el estrado de ha sido
consumado y el rechazo mayoritario del
pueblo de venezuela ha sido evidente
sólo hacen fraude en los que le temen al
pueblo y maduro y su régimen perdió todo
el apoyo popular entre los diputados
elegidos se encuentran la primera dama
cecilia flores y el vicepresidente del
partido socialista unido de venezuela
diosdado cabello los resultados también
han recibido el rechazo de al menos 16
países del grupo de lima además de eeuu
canadá y otras naciones europeas que
también catalogaron la votación como un
fraude